were you guys best friends before you
started the podcast yes yeah this is our
third podcast we've our third or fourth
podcast we started comedy together in
Philly yeah and Ari said only you two
idiots would try again for a fourth time
and then it actually worked yeah yeah
well what happened the first time did uh
we did we started a pod we started we
were in Philadelphia together and uh we
were down there for about 5 years and
then moved up here and when we got up
here you know we kind of had the in New
York not up here up yeah I'm sorry when
we got to New York we kind of knew that
you know we were somewhat on our own and
had to try to figure something out
between us um but were you guys without
the podcast I mean when you came into
the New York scene yeah we were friends
in Philly but were you accepted into the
New York scene right away or did you
have to struggle a little bit oh it was
I mean no it was a struggle yeah
everybody struggles uh we started like
you know the really shitty bar shows for
you know you're doing 10 12 of those a
week just you know for two three people
sometimes 40 a lot of times 5 6 you're
doing that till 1:00 a.m. going home
working a day job yeah going out you
know changing in McDonald's bathroom to
go do sets and stuff like that no money
you know how long did that last a couple
years and then you know we were working
in the city different clubs I was
hosting a lot at New York comedy club
got to meet a lot of people you know
through that through hosting uh he was
doing the road a little bit and the
whole time we were doing another podcast
together just kind of just a like you
know bullshitting around podcast didn't
really pick up any Steam and then we
started doing one just me and him right
before uh areu garbage called hard
feelings where it was just me and him
sitting in my car bitching about our
days you know going through all that
stuff and had about 50 people listening
most of family and friends wow but the
whole time we always kind of [__] on
each other about how we grew up like you
know you did this growing up you did
that growing up blah blah blah blah blah
and that's kind of where the idea came
from and then we played it on the old
podcast uh once together and then we
were like [__] that's you know that that
was really fun that was really good and
then right before the pandemic we both
were kind of like hey we should do that
as a podcast cuz it's us stripped down
to our most natural form of trash and
then like classic our Bozo fashion we
start it dump all the money we have into
it which is like a couple hundred bucks
you know what I mean like we're like all
right we're like rented a studio we're
going to pay them to shoot it I'll learn
how to do the Clips I'll learn how to do
all the stuff wow and then the world
shut there the world shut we had three
oh it shut it shut down the pandemic
happened in our third week of launching
arug guard oh my God and I was just like
I remember I was talking with my wife
and I was just like I can't fail again
it was like one of those like movie
moments I'm like I cannot fail again I
can't have another failed project like
this [__] sucks wow so we just like
doubled up and the the pandemic kind I
wanted to check out the Hawaii it helped
us he was like he was ready to [__] got
got my stimulus check and I was gone
12200 can't tell me [__] you were going
to get out no I don't know I was just
like what the [__] are we going to do
yeah so we just knuckled up and we're
like let's do a hard a hard feelings
every day for a half an hour and let's
do two episodes of areu garbage every
week over zoom and like so we wanted
like all of these guests like New York
guests that we we're going to try to get
the schultzes the soders the Normans the
list like all those guys and it would
have taken
us uh 18 months to get them all with
schedules like if the world didn't shut
down but now they're all home they all
know us and like us from like working in
the club and so like you we just hit up
Schultz hey you know when he was blowing
up and you're like my potty's like I can
do it this
afternoon through all through Zoom
that's what everybody was doing through
and everybody was cool as [__] and and
were awesome about it great advocates
for us and wow and then then you just
saw the numbers go up so they started
going up and then after that uh we kind
of the world kind of started opening up
a little bit and we we had some steam
and then my wife God bless her she had
uh $10,000 in her savings account dumped
it all into a studio and then for months
then is that the studio I went to yeah
that's the studio you went to oh wow wow
wow wow wow wow we just we got a new one
in March yeah we just built a we got a a
big it's like oh we have offices and two
studos k it's crazy congratulations
thanks buddy now we're here talking to
you guys which is surreal yes why I
remember when you guys first started we
I would watch you I was I've always been
a big podcast fan so like yeah to sit
here with you guys in the it's crazy
it's so [__] cool yeah I mean Whitney
was what the person that originally
turned me on to you she's been a big
Advocate yeah you got to know these guys
she was awesome and then when Jeremiah
and you guys were hanging out the store
yeah we talked about that shout out to
Jeremiah he came you came and Ved us
them
yeah they're fatter than I thought the
one's really ugly those aren't two guys
I want to do a human thing but I guess
they'll do and then you guys went to
Norms came and you hung out H out with
you guys and Jeremiah was like oh [__]
Bobby's Bobby might coming and then he
saw you get out of the car and he's like
Bob's here he's like he's vetting you
I've been asking him to come out to
dinner with me for years and he says no
he's he's coming to put you guys through
the ringer I know I I know